JOEL LEWIS: Hi.
Welcome back to recitation.
In lecture, you've been
learning about Stokes' Theorem,
and I have a nice exercise on
Stokes' Theorem for you here.
So I'm going to
let F be this field
that I've written just above me.
So it's 2x*z minus 2y comma 2y*z
plus 2x comma x square plus y
square plus z square.
And I've got C.
So C is this
complicated-looking curve here.
So it sort of dips up
and down and back around.
But the thing I'm
really going to tell you
about it is that it all lies
on this cylinder of radius b.
So C is this curve in
the cylinder of radius b
that wraps around it once,
but behaves kind of oddly
while it's wrapping around.
So what I'd like
you to do is I'd
like you to use Stokes'
Theorem to compute
the integral around this
curve of F dot dr. Now,
my hint to you is that
for Stokes' Theorem,
you can use-- just like you
have for Green's Theorem
and for Divergence Theorem
that we've talked about before,
you have these
extended versions that
let you consider more
than one boundary piece.
So the same thing works
for Stokes' Theorem.
So Stokes' Theorem
works perfectly well
when you have a piece
of a surface with more
than one boundary curve,
provided you orient everything
correctly.
So you might think about how
you can use Stokes' Theorem
to replace this complicated
curve with a surface integral
and an easier to
understand curve.
And if you can do that,
then computing the other two
gives you the third one.
All right.
So that's my hint to you
for computing this integral.
So why don't you pause the
video, have a go at that,
come back, and we can
work on it together.
Hopefully, you had some luck
working on this problem.
Let's talk about it.
So before I left, I
gave you this hint
that maybe the thing to do here
isn't to try and parametrize
this curve directly and compute
the line integral directly
since it's a
complicated-looking curve,
and also since I haven't really
given you enough information
to do that, and instead to think
about applying Stokes' Theorem.
So to think about applying
Stokes' Theorem, what we'd like
is a nice surface, with this
curve as part of its boundary.
Well, what is such a surface?
Well, this curve lies all
on the cylinder of radius b.
So a natural choice
for a surface
is to use some piece
of this cylinder.
So maybe we could use the
piece of this cylinder
with this as its upper boundary.
So then what might be a natural
lower boundary to choose?
Well, we just want to choose
something nice and simple.
Right?
So, what's nice and simple?
Well, maybe we can
choose this bottom circle
that's in the plane y equals x.
All right.
So I'm going to call
that circle C_1.
So that's the circle of
radius b in the xy-plane.
Sorry, not the plane y equals x.
The xy-plane.
The plane z equals 0.
So we've got the top curve C
and we've got this bottom curve
C_1.
Now, the way I've
oriented them, I've
oriented them both so that
they're going counterclockwise
as you look down
from the z-axis.
So in that case, what
does Stokes' Theorem say?
Well, Stokes' Theorem
says that the integral
over the piece of the
surface between them--
let's call it S-- of curl F
dot n with respect to surface
area is equal to-- OK.
So let's say we can give it the
outward pointing normal, say.
In which case, C_1 will
be positively oriented
and C will be
negatively oriented.
So this is equal to
the line integral
over C_1 of F dot dr minus
the line integral over C
of F dot dr.
And so what's nice
about this formula
is that it replaces computing
the integral that we want.
Instead of computing that,
we can try and compute
this other line integral
and this surface integral.
And if these are
easier to compute,
then computing the two of them
gives us what the value of this
is just by subtracting, or
by adding and subtracting,
or whatever.
By arithmetic, right?
So if these integrals
are easy to compute,
then that makes this one
easy without actually having
to parametrize and compute it.
So let's take a look at
what these integrals are.
Let's do the surface integral
first since it's on the left.
So in order to compute
the surface integral,
we're going to need to
compute the curl of F.
So OK.
So F is this kind of
messy-looking thing here.
So curl of F, well,
what have we got?
So it's going to be
big thing times i hat.
So it's going to be i hat
times this determinant, right?
So let me write the determinant.
So on top we've got
i hat, j hat, k hat,
then we have the partial
x, partial y, partial z,
and then we have the components.
So these are 2x*z minus
2y, and 2y*z plus 2x,
and x square plus y
square plus z square.
All right.
So that's i hat,
j hat, and k hat.
And then we've got
partial over partial x,
partial over partial y,
and partial over partial z.
So this is what the
curl is, and so now we
have to expand this out.
So for i, it's going to be
partial y of x squared plus y
squared plus z
squared-- so that's 2y--
minus partial z of 2y*z plus
2x, so that's minus 2y, i hat.
Plus-- for j hat, it's going to
be partial z of 2x*z minus 2y,
so that's 2x-- minus partial
x of x squared plus y squared
plus z squared, so
that's minus 2x, j hat.
Plus-- for k hat, we want
partial x of 2y*z plus 2x,
so that's 2-- minus
partial y of 2x*z minus 2y,
so that's minus minus 2,
so that's plus 2, k hat.
Oh.
All right.
OK.
So the i-component is 0
and the j-component is 0.
So this is a nice, simple one.
So the curl here, the
k-component is just 4.
So this is equal to 4k.
OK.
So that's what the curl of F is.
Now what do we need to compute?
We need to compute curl of F dot
the normal vector with respect
to surface area.
Now let's look at
what our surface is.
Our surface is right here, and
it's this vertical cylinder.
Well, what is the normal
vector of a vertical cylinder?
Well, it's pointing
straight away from the axis.
Right?
It's perpendicular to the
surface of the cylinder,
so it's parallel
to the xy-plane.
It rotates as you go
around the cylinder,
but it's always in the xy-plane.
So what does that mean?
Well, that means
in particular, it's
perpendicular to things
in the z-direction.
Right?
So if we look, we see our curl
here is just straight upward
in the z-direction.
And our normal vector
has no z-component.
It's only in the xy-plane.
So this k hat is
orthogonal to n, OK?
So the curl and
n are orthogonal.
So their dot product is 0.
So this surface integral
is a surface integral of 0.
So it just gives you 0.
OK.
So great.
So that's really nice.
That simplifies
our life very much.
Now, our line
integral that we want.
We just have it in terms of
this one other line integral.
Right?
So the surface integral is 0.
And let me see.
Where should I put this?
OK, the curl is 4k, so the
surface integral curl F dot n
dS is also equal to 0.
So having made that
simplification,
now we just need
this other integral.
We need this line
integral over C_1.
And that'll give
us what we need.
So let's have a go at that.
So C_1 is the circle
of radius b centered
at the origin in the xy-plane.
OK.
I'm not going to
write that down.
I'm just going to say it.
The circle of radius b centered
at the origin in the xy-plane.
So OK.
So it's not that
hard to parametrize.
So it's parametrized by
x equals b cosine theta,
y equals b sine theta.
We should check.
We should double-check
that we're
doing the right direction
of parametrization.
Let's go have a look.
Let's see.
Yes.
OK.
So we parametrized
this circle going
counterclockwise
in the xy-plane.
So good.
So this parametrization is
going the right direction.
Otherwise, we'd have to change
the sign of theta or something.
So it's x is b cosine
theta, y is b sine theta.
And we're going once
around the circle,
so we want 0 less than or equal
to theta less than or equal
to 2*pi.
And so what do we have?
So now, we want to
compute the integral
over the circle of F dot
dr. So let's see what
F looks like in this situation.
So let's go back and look at
the expression for F over here.
So in this plane, we
have z is equal to 0.
So F is minus 2y, plus 2x,
x squared plus y squared.
OK?
OK, so let's come back then.
So F is what I
just said, so this
is equal to the integral
over C of minus 2y dx,
plus 2x dy-- plus x
squared plus y squared dz,
but we're in the
plane z equals 0,
so dz is always
0 in that plane--
so we don't have a
third term there.
Great.
So this is our
integral, and now we
can substitute from our
parametrization here.
So this is equal to the
integral from 0 to 2*pi.
So minus 2y dx.
So that's minus 2b
sine theta, times-- dx
is minus b sine theta
d theta-- plus 2x-- so
that's 2b cosine theta-- times
dy, which is b cosine theta d
theta.
Whew.
This is quite a long
equation, isn't it?
Or a long expression, I guess.
So our line integral around
C of F dot dr is equal
to the integral from 0 to 2*pi
of minus 2b sine theta times
minus b sine theta d theta.
So this is 2b squared sine
squared theta d theta.
And this is 2b cosine
So OK.
So that 2 b squared
is a constant.
We can just factor it out.
And we're left with sine squared
theta plus cosine squared theta
d theta.
All right.
OK.
That's great.
I'm happy to have that.
Right?
Sine squared theta
plus cosine squared
theta, that's going to be 1.
OK.
So we can rewrite this.
I'm going to bring
it back up here.
So that's equal to the integral
from 0 to 2*pi of 2 b squared d
theta, which is 4*pi b squared.
Great.
OK, so that's our line integral
around this bottom curve C.
Oh, dear.
I've been writing C, but this
is not our original curve C,
this is our new curve
C_1, like I wrote there.
Sorry.
So everywhere I wrote the
line integral over C--
both of these places--
it was supposed
to be a line integral over C_1.
Sorry about that.
So we've got this line
integral over C_1,
and it worked out
to 4*pi b squared,
just using our usual
parametrize-and-compute
technique for computing
line integrals.
So OK.
So now, let's see
where we're at.
Let's go back over here
to when we wrote down
what the extended Stokes'
Theorem says in our case.
So Stokes' Theorem
told us that the thing
we were interested
in-- this is the thing
we're trying to compute, right?
The problem asked us to
compute the line integral
over C of F dot
dr. Well, extended
Stokes' Theorem said, in
order to compute this line
integral, what you can do is
you can compute this surface
integral over S, and you
can compute this line
integral over this
other curve C_1,
and then these three things have
to satisfy this relationship.
That's what's
Stokes' Theorem says.
And now we've computed.
We've computed the
surface integral,
and we found it was equal to 0
by a simple geometric argument
that didn't require us to
actually compute a surface
integral.
And we computed this
line integral, just now,
by parametrizing
and computing it.
So OK.
So this was 0 and this
was 4*pi b squared.
So if we just add our
integral in question
to the other side,
what we find--
I'm going to go find some empty
board space to write it down--
so our integral, the
integral over C of F
dot dr is equal to this other
line integral minus the surface
integral.
So it's equal to 4*pi
b squared minus 0.
Just rearranging that equation
we were looking at a second
ago from Stokes' Theorem.
So it's just 4*pi b squared.
So that's the answer,
and I'll end there.